In order to understand Rousseff, we need to start with her predecessor,...
...President Luiz Inacio Lula da Silva, aka Lula.
A rags-to-riches story, Lula was wildly popular...
...and became a symbol for Brazil's economic ascent...
...as one of the top exporters in the world of commodities...
...such as oil, soybeans, corn and iron ore.
Dilma Rousseff was Lula's protege...
...and became the first woman to be elected president of Brazil in 2010.
During Rousseff's presidency, global prices for raw materials began dropping.
And a corruption scandal paralyzed many infrastructure projects,...
...putting severe strain on Brazil's economy.
How bad did it get?
Brazil's economy shrank 3.8 percent in 2015,...
...the most in a quarter century.
The country's credit rating was downgraded to junk.
And business and consumer confidence levels fell to nearly their lowest on record.